[Music]
hello my name is colin rendell and today
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
a package i've been working on recently
called parse
rmd this package implements a parser for
our markdown documents using the boost
spirit library in c
plus and exposes a series of functions
and data structures that allow for the
manipulation and evaluation
of our markdown documents from within r
so to give you a little bit of context
i teach large statistical computing
courses and i deliver assignments to
students in the form of our markdown
documents
um these are markdown documents have
very typical structures so they have
things like yaml at the beginning
section headings to keep bits and pieces
organized instructions in the form of
markdown text
and then various code chunks that
include either example code or areas
where we want students to enter their
own code
to implement a solution or something
like that and this works really really
well
except one of the difficulties we have
is that the documents contain lots of
boilerplate
in the form of these instructions or
demo code that we don't actually care
about when it comes time to market and
actually distracts from
the content that we are really concerned
with and so part of the motivating
reason for developing the parse rmd
package
was a desire to be able to take these
kind of documents once the students have
turned them in
and then strip out all of that
boilerplate to get down to just the
stuff that we actually care about
and so today i'll show you some examples
of what that looks like in practice
so at its core is this parse underscore
rmd function which reads in
our markdown document and then turns it
into a simple abstract syntax tree
and so for our purposes right now we
don't really need to understand what
that is but the key thing to see is
all of those elements we just saw in
that homework01.rmd are here so we see
that there's the yaml is represented
we have the various section headings we
have the markdown text
and the code chunks and this is
presented in a hierarchical way but it's
really
just flat we're just inferring the
hierarchy based on the various heading
levels that we see within the document
if this hierarchical view doesn't work
for you we can also turn this into
a tidy rectangle of data using the
aztival function and so what we now have
is the same representation of that data
where that ast has been wrapped up into
a table and we can manipulate things by
looking at the various other columns
that are there but that ast we were just
seeing
is still here it's now just in its flat
form represented in that ast column on
the right hand side
so ast what is that how do i work with
it what do i care about it's a custom
data structure but it's really just a
list of lists and it's all managed by
s3 and it's not something that you
actually need to worry about in practice
because the package implements a bunch
of helper functions
so if we want to subset for various
elements so in the example i have
i care about the exercises and the
solutions so here i can use the subset
function to pull out
anything that matches exercises with a
wild card and then solution
so this gets me all of the nodes that
belong to an exercise one two or three
and then the various answers the
students may have put into those
particular
bits of the document i can pull those
out once i've done that i can then also
manipulate the document further so a
common issue students have is they may
write code that has an error and if we
were to try to knit that document we
would not be able to because of the
error
so what we can do is we can then
manipulate the code chunks to add new
options so this is going to go through
and set error equal to true for all of
the code chunks
so that when we knit the document it'll
keep knitting even if there is an error
at any point in the document
once we've done that we can then say
turn the document back into text
or we can even just render it directly
so in this case i could turn it back
into an html document and examine it
um and so again this makes it very easy
to then take the student's code
pull out the pieces i want and then
render just the solution so that i can
then mark it much more easily without
all of that other sort of cruft around
this works really well in practice it's
a little bit more difficult because we
depend on the structure of the
document matching exactly what we expect
when we're extracting things
and so one of the things that i've also
done in practice with this that's been
able to be built on top of these tools
is the idea of a template an automatic
feedback for the students so an rmd
template
is just a simple representation of the
nodes that we expect to find
and the various sort of labels and
location references that we care about
to indicate where they are and it's just
a simple table that we can generate
using the rmd template function once
we've subseted for the elements we want
and once we have that we can then feed
it into another helper function called
rmd check template
which we can then use that to compare
against the students work so here i'm
comparing against homework01-student
and we get a user-friendly error message
out telling you exactly what's missing
or what's problematic about the document
so in this case
the student is missing something in
exercise one and exercise two
and they're told explicitly what that is
either a code chunk or markdown text or
what it's
particularly looking for in that context
and so this is something we're actually
able to deploy to students this semester
via github actions
and if it's something that you're
interested in all of the example code
including the github action workflows
are included in the repo that i've
linked at the bottom there
thank you very much for watching
additional details about the package are
available on github and please let us
know if you have any feedback
on the package breaks or you have an
interesting use case
thanks
[Music]
you